[Musique]
moi je crée un contenu exclusif que
personne d'autre n'est capable de faire
bienvenue en Arctique
aujourd'hui
je suis sponsorisé par une grande marque
de montre personne va aller se [__] au
Pôle Nord à moins 70 ou alors deux ou
trois personnes au monde
j'ai vendu mon côté papa explorateur
j'ai vendu le fait que je suis un des
seuls de ma génération a réussi à
évoluer dans tous les biops
le show le froid
sur l'eau en Amazonie ça aujourd'hui et
qui peut dire qu'il fait aussi
[__]
coucou mes fifilles il me tarde de
rentrer à la maison je me suis retrouvé
à plein de moments de ma vie à essayer
d'avoir un coup de téléphone à mes
enfants et d'entendre de l'autre côté
j'ai pas envie de te parler en fait il
aime se retrouver dans des situations
inconfortables
oui il a la vie la mort et il doit tout
casser entre
également
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui est
bercé par l'extrême c'est son matelas
c'est dur aujourd'hui
on a fait des conneries on va charbonner
beaucoup quand on était plus jeune avec
le frangin on faisait quand même pas mal
de conneries ensemble
et c'est vrai que notre père a été
extrêmement dur
je crois pas que c'est des choses qui se
disent sur les caméras ça
[Musique]
dans l'extrême
la drogue des arrêts cardiaques
[Musique]
tout ce que j'entrepris dans ma vie j'ai
été border 99,9% du temps
[Musique]
avec quelle chaussure quelle marque de
chaussures
pendant très longtemps ma marque de
fabrique a été de marcher pieds nus les
gens se rappelaient de moi partout
j'allais parce que je marchais ça va
être quand même un enfer
ouais ça va faire après c'est c'est une
façon de devoir les choses dans une
grande surface dans une boutique de luxe
dans un rendez-vous pour vendre une
maison à 350 000 balles j'étais pieds
nus et je me suis dit je vais faire la
différence comme ça les gens vont se
rappeler de moi pour la bonne ou la
mauvaise raison on va quand même se
rappeler de moi c'est ma marque de
fabrique vous le savez mieux que moi on
habite dans une résidence royale
du coup voilà je suis ici
[Musique]
à cette époque là on fait un nom il
fallait que je prenne des risques c'est
comme ça que tu enfonces des portes si
tu restes assis dans ton canapé à
attendre combien de te dire ah ouais
c'est toi louri lag l'explorateur
incroyable qui a jamais rien fait waouh
et personne ne va jamais rien donné
il faut se faire il faut se fabriquer il
faut s'inventer il faut prendre des
risques
si tu crois que tu es fait pour ça il
faut y aller à fond
[Musique]
fort fort fort sur
une belle olive comme ça là
[Musique]
quand tu vas chercher une adrénaline
n'importe quel addict peut-on parler tu
vas chercher une sensation et tu vas
chercher toujours plus haut
[Musique]
finalement on va se retrouver sur un lit
de mort et qu'on est tous destinés à
avoir cette fin là ça me dépasse
de me dire que quand on va arriver à ce
moment-là on dira ah bah si j'avais su
j'aurais fait des choses avant ben non
j'y suis là en fait avant je vois pas
pourquoi en fait je ferais pas des
choses incroyables ou des choses que
j'ai envie ou les choses qui m'animent
ou les choses que j'ai envie d'essayer
j'y suis j'ai envie de le faire et je
vais le faire